[Music]
Greetings to you our beloved friends and
family members of some TV and I'd like
to know this wonderful question and
answer program. So good that you have
decided to join us and to be with us
during this quickly moving half hour as
we take your questions and answer them
from the word of God. My name is CA
Murray. I'm in the company of our
general manager of SMTV Latino, Pastor
David Salazar.
>> Thank you, Pastor.
>> And our president and founder, Pastor
Steven Bor. Gentlemen, good to have you
both here.
>> Amen.
>> Uh want to do a little housekeeping, a
little homework. If you want to get in
on the fun, be part of the program, we
invite you to do so by writing to
tvsumtv.org.
That's tvsum
su m as in Mary tv.org
and we will answer your questions from
the word of God. Pastor Salazar, if you
would pray for us, then we'll read this
first question and uh we're going to
have to take our time with it because it
does have several elements to it.
>> Let us pray.
Heavenly Father, we come before you with
humble hearts realizing the need that we
have of your direction of your Holy
Spirit to put in our minds, put in our
hearts, in our lips, the right answers
that your word may be really in our mind
and in our lips so that we may answer
according to your will and may bring
those who are watching, those who are
listening, may they be able to receive a
blessing as we open your word. Uh thank
you for being with us and we pray this
in Jesus name. Amen.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. This question comes to us from
Patrick and he is writing to us from
Finland. So, hello Finland. Uh, nice to
know they're reaching all the way up to
Northern Europe there. Thank you for
writing your question, Patrick. Having
said so, it is a bit of an involved one.
So, I'm going to ask you to turn your
Bibles to Revelation chapter 20. Uh, he
is considering in particular verses
4-14.
So, let's look at the question. Isn't
the judgment before the great white
throne which is mentioned in this
particular chapter in Revelation 20 4-14
the second resurrection
verse 4-6
is the first resurrection and 11-15
is the second they are talking about
judgment and they who are in the first
resurrection will not be judged or will
If not, then we talk about the second
resurrection. But it is strange that
they open the book of life and check if
anyone was written in it. Doesn't Jesus
or God know that no one in the in the
second resurrection is written in the
book of life? Does only or do only SDAs
know about it? I'm a little I'm being a
little sarcastic here. So he says he's
being sarcastic, but it's it's based on
his his slight bit of confusion as to
what this text is actually saying.
>> Okay, I think that probably we should
start by reading the ver verses and
let's try to direct the the instructions
or the teaching there in in what the
Bible's really saying. in revelation
chapter 20 vers 4. I'm going to read uh
verses 4-6 as he's asking and we'll
you know discuss about those verses
before we move on. It says there and I
saw thrones and they sat on them and
judgment was committed to them. Then I
saw the souls of those who had been
beheaded for their witness to Jesus and
for the word of God, who had not
worshiped the beast or his image, and
had not received his mark on their
foreheads or in their hands. And they
lived and reign with Christ for a
thousand years. But the rest of the dead
did not live again until the thousand
years were finished. This is the first
resurrection.
And verse six says, "Blessed and holy is
he who has part in the first
resurrection. Over such the second death
has no power, but they shall be priests
of God and of Christ and shall reign
with him a thousand years." So these
first verses are clearly indicating who
partakes of the first resurrection and
what is their role, their duty while the
thousand years is taking place. They are
reigning with Jesus.
But also they are sitting with Christ to
judge. Judgment is committed to them.
These are the the people who are
redeemed uh who are resurrected in the
first resurrection. They have a thousand
years to sit with Christ to judge and to
um
uh to enjoy and to have that experience
of being priests and kings with Jesus.
And they shall rule with him a thousand
years. So and the Bible is emphasizing
blessed is and he blessed and holy is he
who has part in the first resurrection.
So I think this is very clearly
indicating the role the duty of those
who are redeemed and h why they are
considered blessed and holy because they
have the ability to reign with Christ
for years.
>> Revelation 20 is a complex chapter.
Uh this is a very difficult question to
answer even in two programs back to back
>> because Revelation chapter 20 through
21:8
actually has four repetitive cycles.
>> Verses 1:3 contain the basic outline.
Verses 4-10
repeat the same thing with an expansion.
verses 11 through chapter 21:1
>> gives you a third cycle and Revelation
21 verse 2-8 gives you the last
repetitive cycle. Each one adds details
to the previous cycle. Uh in other
words, all three cycles give you events
at the beginning of the millennium,
during the millennium and after the
millennium. Uh now when when you uh look
at these four outlines
uh each one has a special focus
>> emphasis. Yeah.
>> Uh the first cycle Revelation 21
through3 is dealing with what happens
with Satan and the earth
>> right
>> at the beginning during and at the end
of the millennium.
Verses 4-10 are dealing with what
happens with the saints during be at the
beginning, during and after the
millennium.
Then you have uh the next cycle which is
revelation 20 and verses 11 through
chapter 21 and verse one. Once again you
have the beginning of the millennium,
during the millennium and after the
millennium in the focus and then you
have the focus on the wicked. Revelation
21 verses 2 through8.
>> Well said.
>> And each one ends with the lake of fire.
>> There's not three lakes of fire.
>> There's only one lake of fire. But each
outline is reaching the same conclusion.
>> Yes.
>> Now when you keep this in mind, then
you're able to organize
this and understand it a little better.
Um let's let's just take for example uh
chapter 20 and verse4 which is what you
read.
>> And I saw thrones and they sat on them
and judgment was committed to them. By
the way, the judgment is committed to
those who were judged before the second
coming.
>> But the judgment before the second
coming doesn't come to view in
Revelation 20. No,
>> because that's already taken place.
>> So it says, "And I saw thrones and they
sat on them and judgment was committed
to them. Then I saw uh those souls of
those who had been beheaded for their
witness to Jesus and for the word of God
who had not worshiped the beast or his
image and had not received his mark on
their foreheads or on their hands and
they lived and reigned with Christ for a
thousand years.
>> So they resurrect at the beginning of
the thousand years and judgment is
committed to them. But then now comes a
parenthetical statement.
>> Yes. Mhm.
>> Uh yeah. And matter of fact, many
versions place parentheses around the
beginning of verse 5 up to the word
finished.
>> Yeah.
>> Because you you want to know, well, what
about uh the rest of the dead? You know,
the the the righteous dead have have
resurrected and judgment is committed to
them, but what about the other dead?
>> Well, you place parenthesis, but the
rest of the dead did not live again
until the thousand years were finished.
Right?
>> You close the parenthesis. Mhm.
>> And then uh the end of verse 5 becomes
the conclusion to verse four.
>> Correct.
>> So in other words, you skip the
parenthesis and what it's saying is and
they lived and reigned with Christ for a
thousand years. This is the first
resurrection.
>> Correct?
>> If you don't do that, you'll be you'll
be like Confucious.
>> Yes. You become
>> you won't be able to understand. And
then it continues in verse six, blessed
and holy as he who has pardoned the
first resurrection over such the second
death which is after the millennium.
>> Correct?
>> The second death has no power but they
shall be priests of God and of Christ
and shall reign with him a thousand
years. Now one more thing uh be before I
finish my remarks. The reason why the
book of life is brought to view
after the millennium is not because the
righteous are being uh judged to find
out if their name is in the book of
life.
>> The purpose is to show that the names of
the wicked are not in the book of life.
>> Correct?
>> So in other words, the book of life is
brought out and these people are not
here. And then after it's shown that
they're not there, then they're thrown
into the lake of fire.
>> Precisely. Um I wish I had more time to
really develop this but in my study
notes from the close of probation till
uh the let's see what is the specific
name well to the new earth from the
close of probation to the new earth.
>> I have an entire chapter studying the
sequence of events that we find in
revelation 20. And when you notice how
it's structured everything makes perfect
sense.
>> Amen. Mhm. Having gone through that uh
it occurs to me that that is a very good
tool for you to to buy or download if
you wish uh because it helps you. I
think in the overall picture even though
you have the word then appearing it
doesn't mean that these events follow
sequentially right
>> they lay on top of each other. Uh and
that's the the best way to to to to
understand it. Um uh and and helps you
break it down a little bit better. The
idea that you have a repetition with a
little enlargement or a different view
or aspect uh is key to understanding
understanding this particular chapter.
David, you had something you wanted to
add.
>> Just to add, you know, that I encourage
Patrick to study the scriptures, to
continue to study. I enjoy the fact that
he's trying to find answers and asking
good questions. uh just like pastor B
was mentioning in in in you know because
he has this this question in regards to
why the need to open the book of life
and what not it's again it's verse 12
and I just like to read that verse and
it says and I saw the dead small and
great standing before God and books were
opened and another book was open which
is the book of life and the dead were
judged according to their works by the
things which are written in the books
and So, interestingly enough, the book
of life shows, as you were saying,
pastor, they are not there. But other
books are opened that show their deeds,
everything that they do. The
>> rejection of God's mercy, of his
providence, of his desire to bring them
to the truth or to repentance. The
rejection of the many times that people
in their lives wanted to approach them
and they said no. So ultimately they are
judged
the saints are and apostle Paul speaks
of that that the saints will have the
judgment
>> of the wicked and of the evil angels and
all of them. So it's it's this is what's
speaking of
>> and therefore uh yes they will be open
the books will be opened no one of those
that are dead
>> while the a thousand years are you know
are going on those that are the wicked
there none of them are going to be saved
because they're not found in the book of
life and it's because of their deeds
that are found in the other books of
memory or the books of of all the deeds
of the book of death I guess if you want
to call that you know those things are
going to be there clearly for them to
know they are worthy of destruction.
They're not worthy of of life.
>> And you know, the the fact is that
Revelation 17 verse8
uh explains what appears later in verse
in chapter 20 uh that the purpose of the
book of life being brought forth is to
show that their names are not written.
And the reason why they're not written
is because of the book what appears in
the book of records, right? says in
Revelation 17:8, "Then the beast that
you saw was and is not and will ascend
out of the bottomless pit and go to
predition. And those who dwell on the
earth will marvel whose names are not
written the book of life when they see
the beast that was and is not and yet
is." Mhm.
>> So the purpose of the book of life being
brought out at the end of the
millennium, which is the judgment, the
final punishment of the wicked is to
show that their names are not written in
the book of life. Ellen White describes
this judgment in the last chapter of
great controversy, the controversy
ended. And uh she actually uh uses this
verse revelation chapter uh 20 and verse
12 to speak about uh the judgment that
takes place after the millennium with
the wicked.
>> This this judgment is a little different
than preceding judgments in that it is
not a and I have to use determined by
the active judgment. It is more a
ratification or certification that what
God has done is true. It is the proof
that is needed uh that uh that God doeth
all things well.
>> Amen.
>> And and he and when the names are not in
the book, then you know he did all
things well because the name's not
there. So it's basically certifying that
what was done was done correctly.
>> Yeah. Actually shows every after the
millennium in panoramic view. He's going
to show all the works of the wicked
outside the holy city.
>> And then he's going to say
they're not in the book of life. Did I
do it right?
>> Yeah, cuz I think so.
>> And everybody's gonna say, you did it
right. You did it right.
>> They don't deserve eternal life on the
basis of what we saw in the books.
>> Yeah. Well done.
Thank you, Patrick, for the question. It
shows you are studying. Uh there's
insight in the question and uh we hope
we have done justice to your question.
It's a good question. It's a product of
study and research and uh we thank you
for it. Uh Patrick from Finland. Well
done and uh hopefully we'll hear from
you again. Now uh I thought we had time
to get one more in. This is
Bambbele.
Bamble from Uganda. Again, uh from
Uganda. Are there certain positions a
person can hold that would automatically
close their probation? Specifically, I'm
referring to the position of the pope
based on chapter 12 of the book of the
book of heaven.
>> Well, the book heaven, it's an Ellen
White quote compilation.
>> Ah, the book heaven. Should I assume
that every pope will certainly miss
heaven?
>> Heaven. Is that is that a is that a a
devotional?
>> I'm not It might be a devotional book
that was published. Yes, I think so.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Basically, it tells you what
heaven is going to be like.
>> Um,
>> you know, I'm glad I'm not the judge.
>> Amen.
>> Because everyone everybody would be
lost, including myself.
Um, can I definitely say that because an
individual occupies the position of pope
that that individual is lost? I can't
say that
>> because uh God is the judge. God knows
the trajec trajectory of each person.
>> Yes.
>> And uh so we have to leave it in his
hands. Um
so the answer to the question would be a
position does not necessarily condemn
you.
>> Yeah.
>> I think I I have the quote that he's
referring to is actually a quote that is
uh originally in the book Great
Controversy page 668.
>> So what is the reference to heaven? Um
it has no no because no there is no
there is no what I'm saying the there is
a booklet called heaven
>> and and um it's in found inversy
but the great controversy is the the you
know where it comes from the quote is
from
>> excerted from okay so uh this is what
she says she says uh there are papist
priests and prelates who claim to be
Christ ambassadors ers yet employed the
rank and yet employed the rack, the
dungeon, and the stake to control the
conscience of his people. There are the
proud pontiffs who exalted themselves
above God and presumed to change the law
of the most high. Those pretended
fathers of the church have an account to
render to God from which they would fain
be excused. Too late. They are made to
see that the omnisipent omnis omnisient
one is jealous of his law and that he
will in no wise clear the guilty. They
learn now that Christ defies his
interest with that of us his suffering
people and they feel the force of his
own words is as much as you have done it
unto one of these least of my brethren
you have done it unto me. So this is
she's speaking of those who are not
going to be in heaven those who are
right
>> missing heaven per se. So she does
mention there papist priests pates uh
also the proud pontiffs who exalted
themselves. So you know
>> she didn't say all.
>> She didn't say all exactly and and and
that is perhaps uh you know something to
be careful. We cannot say that the
position of a of a person individually
is what determines whether or not that
person is lost or not. is really having
rejected the influence of the Holy
Spirit and we are judged to the
knowledge that we have and the knowledge
that we rejected or we did not want to
have even though it was close to us.
Think of the example of Kyifas.
He was not a pope or a priest you know
he was I mean he was a priest but I'm
saying he was not a Catholic priest. He
was not you know he was a a Jewish
leader yet because he had pride in his
heart. He was full of pride and
arrogance and had rejected the humble
teaching of Christ and Jesus as a
savior. He's lost. He instigated he
approve of the destruction and the death
of Christ. So therefore we can see that
is not necessarily the position you know
that you are in because he was a a
Hebrew but because of what he did with
what he had in his mind his heart
because of his desire to exalt himself
and to reject the Bible the word of God
he became one who destroyed Christ in a
sense and so uh that's why you know it's
not really the position that makes a
person but you know there's many other
examples in the Bible of of people who
are not going be in heaven because of
the rejection of Jesus or or because of
the pride in their hearts.
>> I I don't think a position per se
disqualifies. Uh certainly when we talk
about the beast, the dragon and the the
mechanisms that is used, we're talking
about the church system. Uh we know that
there are there are good people in in
all denominations and fraternity.
>> Um I echo your sentiment, pastor. I am
glad I am not God. You know, some of
these things we have to they are
delightful academic discussions,
but when the quote rubber meets the
road, God's got to handle that
>> because you may have a person sitting at
the top of a con a a bad system, who has
a good heart? We we don't know.
>> Uh they may come out, they may stay, and
of course, once they pass, their their
their fate is sealed. But
given what you know, it's good to leave
that to God. It's it's very tough. I'
I've had a discussion with with Malachi
Martin was a Jesuit priest. Uh and he he
as died in late 90s. The last discussion
I had with him, he was died in a wool
Catholic. He just wasn't going to
change. And when you give all the the
mistakes and things that the Catholic
Church has done through the years, his
response was, "Well, sometimes mothers
got to spank the children." you know,
that's his mindset. Uh there may be
others who have that mindset, but that's
that's left up up to God. Uh we cannot
make that determination.
>> Yeah. We uh judge not that ye be not
judged.
>> You know, let's leave the judgment into
the hands of God.
>> Yes.
>> Um you know, there's kind of a parallel
here. Of course, these priests came out
from apostate Judaism. But in Acts
chapter 6 and verse 7, it says, "Then
the word of God spread and the number of
the disciples multiplied greatly in
Jerusalem and a great many of the
priests were obedient to the faith."
>> So uh even in uh even in the
>> Sanhedrin,
>> you know, you had Joseph of Arthea, he
was a member of the Sanhedrin and you
have uh uh Nicodemus.
>> Nicodemus. Sure. He was a member of the
Sanhedrin. Saul of Tarsus have mercy.
>> I'd like to see that meeting of Saul of
Tarsus with Stephen because Saul of
Tarsus,
you know, Steven never knew that Saul of
Tarsus, the ring leader,
>> was actually going to become the great
Apostle Paul.
>> Uh you also had Galio, the wise Galio.
>> You know, there's no evidence that he
ever became a Christian.
>> Mhm.
>> But he he was a defender. Yeah.
>> of Peter and John, he said, "Don't lay
your hands on these people because,
>> you know, uh, if this is of God,
nobody's going to be able to eliminate
it, right?
>> If it isn't of God, it's going to
disappear.
>> Going to die."
>> So, you know, Duke Frederick that
protected Luther. Of course, he wasn't a
pope or a priest,
>> right?
>> But there's individuals that never
actually joined a movement
>> that were instrumental in helping God's
people.
>> Only God knows.
>> Only men. And many people will come out
of that system as the Bible says come
out of they're my people you know kind
of her my people. So there is people of
God that are faithful to what they know
in the system priests and you know so
again the judgment is up to the Lord and
thankfully not for us to know
>> you mentioned a good a good point there
in our times get away from us uh to
stand up for Luther in those times
something was happening in his heart.
You know sometimes it's that one act of
standing up for the Lord that changes
the whole course of somebody's life.
Amen.
>> So you cannot you cannot tell. Good
discussion, good questions, uh good
program. Thank you uh for your
questions. They challenge us and they
give us a reason to study the word of
God which we love to do. Uh keep on
studying, keep on sending in your
questions. We like this particular
program because it gives us a chance to
answer and to respond to your queries
and to give an answer from the word of
God. Our time has fast slipped into
eternity. Allow me in closing to wish
you both grace and peace through our
Lord and Savior Jesus Christ. We'll see
you again soon. Bye-bye and God bless.
[Music]